Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Super Mario Maker.
This time, we're approaching the expert level.. levels
Which means that I'm not gonna be able to speak properly
And this is not gonna go well for me
But I'm gonna beat this!
No matter what, no matter what happens , I am gonna conquer this
Because most of these levels have about a ten to five percent clear rate
And that means that one out of ten, or one out of twenty... tries, you succeed.
So to get through sixteen levels of these, I have to lose only about five Marios per level
And this one is just called '2'
And this one is made by someone from Japan, so I'm assuming it's gonna be hard.
But I'm willing!
I'm a champion ba- ooh
Thank you for that!
I don't know if I was supposed to get that but that's good
Okay, so far so not bad
Am I supposed to go down here? No? Okay.
Oh God, it's Companion Spring Hell all over again.
Ah! Screw you, assbags!
Ahh!
[Markiplier noises]
Okay, so I can do this. I can get a one-up if I do this
Yes. YES. That's three one ups. Okay, so that's already more than I need
Crap, where am I supposed to go?
Oh no, I was supposed to do...
Oh NO.
[Nervous laughter]
Aaah, damn it!
Yes! OH, I'm that good, I'm that good
I'm that good!
Yeah- NO! Aah, I'm not that good!
Aah I'm not that good.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay. I got this.
So long as I get the levels with the easy one-ups, I think everything's...
Well, that... one-ups didn't mean anything on that try because
frankly, I didn't comeplete the level yet, I forgot that's kind of a requirement on this shindig
we call LIFE. Get out of my face!
I need to get to the end of this level
before I lose my goddamn mind.
I mean, it's a little early for me to be losing my goddamn mind, so let's... let's take this...
Shiiiit.
Fuck, no. Ah.
No.
NO.
GODDAMN IT.
NO!
Alright. And this is just the beginning
This is just the beginning of when I lose my goddamn mind
'Cause I intentionally stayed away from the super hard levels
For my- God, I'm not going to be able to get past that, am I?
Maybe now that I'm small and aerodynamic I now might'll be able to get through.
heh!
Aaaaah right into the side of it!
It was just so bulbous and red that I couldn't help ramming my body into him
Aw man, I'm already three down.
Shut up! I'm not going to pass, don't be patronizing about me.
I know my limitations, I know what I can do
So you shut your goddamn trap hole
I'm gonna get this
If it's the last thing I do
Okay outside, twirl, twirl! YES!
Okay got it, alright so go next...
Fuck! Me! Aw, goddammit.
So I need to go down, oh. Ah. YES. Okay.
Aaah.
Aaaaah.
Jumps. Difficult. Okay any of these have anything for me?
A Mush? Goddamn it. No mush. I DON'T HAVE A MUSH! AW I NEED A MUSH!
Aaaagh Damn it! Aaaa poop!
Ok, so maybe I can go back, get a mush 'cause I remember there was a bunch of mushes down there
Maybe that's a thing... AAAaaa frick a dick!
Ok I just gotta get a mush, I gotta keep my mush
Which I had I-ha I-I-I-I had it
I had the mush. Aaa fuck you. Goddamn it.
Okay, so this is not a problem, I just gotta get the mush
Gotta get through here
Just...
Well that's not what I wanted to do
Ok! I'll take it! I'll take it. I'll take it... I'll take it
I don't know how I did that, but I'll take it.
Okay, so I gotta get over here
And down here is the sproingy-do
These... I'll just take them all.
I like the points.
And then... and perfect!
Perfect! Exactly what I was supposed to be able to do there.
Oh! Aaaaah goddammit son of an ass, man!
I know what I need to do now, at least for this part of the stage
I have no idea what's coming at the end of the stage
Or why it's taking me so long to get through this
because frankly, this is kind of eas-
[loud blabbing]
Son of a bitch!
This time, no jokes.
Noooo joking around.
I know what I need to do
and I'm gonna do it efficiently.
I don't even neeeeeed the mushes.
Sss.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
So I just gotta take this calmly enough.
Collectedly enough- Yes! Okay.
So now I spin jump on these...
I thought-
Wait, what?
Wait, I thought you could-
There's something down there, isn't there?
There's- ohhhhhohohoho I thought there was gonna be nothing
Oh YES!
YEAH!
Yeah! Yeah!
Yea- that was all a trick!
That was just a fricking trick!
I wouldn't even know how you would get over there in the first place.
I did it! Yes!
So I got some extra Marios back, so
this is boding well for me.
It didn't bode well for me for a long time
You guys were already giving up on me
Saying that I was gonna be
Nary a chance that anything was gonna go bad
But that's one level down and I only
I've got 97
I don't know why I did this
But that's my celebratory move
Don't you guys know about that?
My favorite thing to do after I win
Anyway
Ah!
Missed me,
Missed, missed
Dick
DICK
Miiiiissed me
Alright
So what do we got going on here?
This one if, if anything goes wrong in this one it's gonna
take a LONG time to get back to it
But that's why I'm a freakin' badass
and I know exactly-
I'm gonna save this, 'cause I don't know when this is gonna be needed
shut up
okay
So we got one going up
oh no
Aww!
Why???? Eh
Why????
Why can't I hit these?
Oh god, OH GOD
Oh Gawd
Oh Gersh
okay
Everything's fine,
I still got the pow.
I don't why I got the pow-
I need to go down there, don't I?
Oh no- (Markiplier noises)
Give give give give give give give give
give to meeee
GIVE TO MEEEE
(more random noises)
(sporadic random noises)
Oh, I coulda just gone down here,
that woulda been easy.
Maybe that woulda just been a mush.
And it wouldn't have got me what I needed.
That's all?
Easy peasy!
Don't you dare.
I like how all the goombas are just wa-
Ah, FRICK!
I like how the goombas are just walkin off into their own demise.
They're so stupid.
Who would fall off a ledge that's right in front of them?
What kinda moron would do that?
Heh,
someone who's obviously bad at games
and name rhymes with
.....Farkiplier....
Farka-Farka....schnier.
Somethin like that, I dunno.
Okay. I still dunno why I have this pow.
I'm assuming that it's gonna be useful at some point.
And I'm assuming that I need to jump on these.
Which I do NOT like.
Okay...... eh.... eh.....
How much more do I need to jump on?
Oh, god.
Oh, god!
(Markiplier noises)
boop
AWWWW, YES!
I DIDN'T GET THE 1-UP BUT I DON'T CARE,
I GOT THE POW!
Yeah, LAND ON THE POW!
I did that.
First try, baby!
I can do this.
But then when it comes to the super expert levels,
I'm not gonna be able to do it, aren't I?
I'm not gonna be-
oh, I was so close to the world record.
Maybe if I'd had just skedaddled a little more.
But that's two down!
That's two down, that's TWO down.
So.
That's good.
T h a t ' s  g o o d .
I feel like my,
I feel like I'm panicking a bit more than I need to
But these are, these are tough
LEV-ELS!
I can't spin jump anymore-
Fuuuudgsicles
(retching noises)
Okay, c'mon.
So long as I can get some more 1-ups too,
because I made the last one with no things
but I didnt get the 1-up at the end of the level.
I was probably supposed to go up that, wasn't I?
(gasps softly)
Waaaassss- boink!
Nice, I'm the best.
Oh, you can go up higher?
Okaaaay.
Niiiiice! Got it.
I'll take it, just in case something goes bad.
Oop!
Thank you.
Up here? No?
Oh, guess I'm supposed to just keep goin' up.
Oh! Perf! Oh, perfect!
Thank you.
Are you gonna shoot one? C'mon.
Hup, boink!
Well that- that's not right.
Oh! Now that I got this, I can go over here.
Duh.
(fart noise)
I didn't even need the fi-
Woooaahh, hey, HA
HA- HEY HEY HEY HEY!
Back up, buddy.
BACK UP, buddy!
What do you think you're doin', huh?
HUH?
Get outta here,
you skeddadle on outta here, you.
I don't like you in my neighborhood.
Hup!
Nah, that's gonna be tough.
So I don't know how I'm gonna be able to go oOOOOOV-
Oh, why, why, why?
He's not gonna skedaddle outta my neighborhood anymore.
AHHHH!
Piss-balls.
Kay, so that's dangerous-looking.
Yeah, I know.
I know that's what I need.
I know,
I knowwww.
(grunts)
Okay, so this is good enough.
I don't know how I'm gonna be able to get these things that they want me to get.
Oh, I'm at a checkpoint!
I'll take that.
Boink, boink, boink!
Uh-oh.
Crap.
Try that once more.
Boink, boink, boink!
FUCK!
C'mon!
Gimme some good.
Boink, boink, boink!
There we go.
HEY, wait, no!
No!
Nooo!
What's this mean?
Oh!
Hey, come back here! I needed that.
Why did he go away?
Why did he have to go away?
Maybe I can boink on your head.
Boink!
Yes, okay.
Got that.
We're down here.
This is a big maze.
But, complicated is a not a problem because I know what I need to do.
Hello,
I don't know what I need to do there.
Ho-ly shit.
That was scary,
do I bounce ON them?
Can I bounce on ghosts with a boot?
I d-d- I don't trust that.
Oh, god.
AWWHHHWHHHH!
(mark's wonderful laughter)
Okay,
everything's gonna be fine,
because I'm gonna go the other way because obviously
I'm not supposed to go the way of the ghosts.
It's a big, lying, lying-pants.
And there's gotta be another path over here.
Well, I was wrong.
But I believe that now,
I should be able to get up the Thwomp.
I can't climb those,
so no I can't!
I've- I've a-screwed myself.
(with a lisp)
I have officially screwed myself over,
to the point where I can't even get back up the god da-
frick-screw-frick
So there's gotta be some puzzle
with the ghosts that shows where I'm supposed to-
lemme, lemme figure out where this goes first.
This is probably gonna lead to nothingness and only my death.
Oh, god.
Oh no, ahhhh!
There was something!
There was something over there!
There WAS!
There was something over there.
Okay, so that- that's good to know.
Oop.
So there was something over there,
I dunno if I could reach it with this one,
but there definitely was.
Ooh, ah! Nevermind.
Oh.
Crap.
Crap-sicle.
What a buncha baloney.
Ah, fine.
Eh!
Kay, so there's gotta be something with those ghosts, right?
There's gotta be something.
There's no notes.
Here we go.
Boink!
Nope, that didn't work.
What are ya supposed to do?
WHYYYYYY
So I'm gonna go all the way back.
I'm gonna go on top of these bitches,
take some of that.
I'm gonna figure out a way to get up here.
No, that's not what I need.
I mean, I would like
another one of these,
that would be nice.
Fuck you.
I mean, I could another Fire Flower,
and that would be delightful.
Nice!
Now,
I'm gonna leave this boot behind for a sec.
Okay so there WAS a way to get up there,
there was a way!
So this-
Ohhh,
OHHHH!
It's the party room!
YEAH!
Okay, good!
Thank you,
you probably don't even know I'm playing the 100 Mario Challenge.
And that was very-
AHHHHHH!
Shit, shit, shit
SHIT! SHIT!
Get up!
AUGH, can I not climb with it?
:/
Duh,
I can bounce on the thing,
the Thwomp, when I have the boot.
Duuuuh!
Ride it up,
and then I'd have the boot on the way out,
DUH!
It makes so much SENSE now!
It makes so much SENSE.
Dammit, I shoulda realized it.
Kay, but I got this.
(fart noise)
Ah! Missed me.
A-boink, boink
Thank you for the nice ride, sir.
You're welcome in my neighborhood.
Okay, so now that I got this,
okay, is this-
do I need to-
how fast do I need to go here?
Oh god.
Are they still-
They're no different!
Wait, what?!
OHHHH, God dammit!
What, I can hit you?
No?
Here we go.
Alright, this is it.
This is the one.
Eat a diiiick,
eat a dick.
(yelling)
AUGH! WHY?
What the FRIIIIII-
Here we go.
Oof.
Oof, yeah!
Checkpoint, baby!
I didn't need anything that I was doing for it,
now I'm gonna blast through this,
because I am the man,
with
the plan!
Okay, that's a little odd.
Not sure what the f-
Not sure how to feel about that one.
That is just-
that is all kinds of bizzare.
Slightly arousing.
Oh wait, that's the end of the stage!
There was no point to this.
There was no point to this!
(strained grunt)
SECRET!
Awwwww, no!
God dammit.
Wasn't a secret,
it was the only way to go.
I'm gonna- I need to abandon this.
I shouldn't have been goin on it in the fir-
AAHHHH! Frick-a-dick!
Frick-a-DIIICK!
(more chicken noises)
There we go,
we got this.
YEAAAHH WE'RE GONNA WIN!
YES!
I got the star!
Okay,
so that is the first episode of
the expert levels in the 100 Mario Challenge.
I still got 90 left.
I got 90 left,
and I took way too long in that level,
but it's okay.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Look forward to more expert levels comin at you real soon,
and as always,
I will see YOU in the next video. (outro music starts)
Buh-bye! (outro music continues)
(Outro Music)